Guys, I don't recommend breaking your
fast alone. If that is meant to be spent
with family and friends, man. I can see
this this pain there. And I believe
there's probably pain in the sister side
as well. Now,
IslamNet is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway,
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a sadaqah jariyah
for you because every person that comes
a step closer [music] to Allah through
your donation, you will inshallah be
reaping the reward. Click the link and
donate what you can. As-salamu alaykum
wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh, brothers
and sisters and dear friends. I'm here
in Mecca in the last 10 nights of the
law. We are going to be into the 29th
night. There was a video that was
circulating, subhanallah, that I came to
saw uh came to see of a brother called
Ish. Uh brother Ish is somebody I've
done a video of 2 3 years ago about him
working in Tesco and all that kind of
stuff. So, I just gave him an naseeha,
the brother. There's nothing wrong wrong
with people working in Tesco as long as
they have a halal income. And I said it
because obviously I don't want people to
have this perception that you need to
live a luxurious life and this which is
there's nothing wrong with that. But, to
um belittle people, not obviously you do
it intentionally. That was my video
about. Anyways, let's move away from
that. Let's talk about his divorce. Now,
why do I do these videos? A lot of
people think I just scroll and I'm like,
you know what? I'm bored, let me just do
videos. I genuinely look at situations
and see if somebody's going through
something or someone's calling to fitna,
then we need to call out against it.
Like Allah says, let there rise among
you a group of people, people who enjoin
good and forbid evil. Okay? And that is
a duty, a duty that makes us distinct
from previous nations which destroyed
other nations cuz they would not do
that. So, brother Ish, there's two
videos we're going to watch of his
divorce, his having a divorce. That's
obviously sad to hear cuz at the end of
the day,
after a video three four months ago
about individuals who are promoting
divorce, you know, take your baby and
leave and all this kind of stuff, and I
was very staunchly
against it. And I stand by it and I have
no regrets. My family members were
dragged into it, my kids, my wife, you
name it. Alhamdulillah, no problem at
all. The haqq We speak the truth even if
they're coming harm us. So, brothers and
sisters, the point is this. I want to
watch these videos and tell and give
brother Ish a naseeha because I'm 36
years old, and he's a young brother, and
I want to give him, and not only him,
for those of our sisters and brothers
who are also going through divorce, to
give some naseeha with some little
experience that I have and my elders
that have given the advice to me. So,
I'm going to inshallah first watch the
video, and then we're going to come and
see inshallah what advice we can give
our brother Ish. Here is the first video
of him announcing his divorce, and a lot
of people thought he was talking about
his barber cuz he's cutting to say his
divorce is barber as a joke. But, here
it is, inshallah, let's watch it for
ourselves.
Okay, so the first video is, as you can
see, him just shaving his head. Um
again, you can make a little assessment
out of this. Uh he might be that he's
upset about the situation, he might be
that he's random. And of course he's
going to be upset. Nobody can deny that
going through a divorce is going to be
something you're happy unless you was
married to an absolute tyrant, which we
can't make claims about that about your
wife cuz we know nothing about your
situation. And this is why it's very
important, guys, not to judge through
assumptions because a lot of times, if
that was a woman doing it, and this is
why nifaqis We're talking about nifaqis
and these, you know, and what's a
nifaqi? There's hijabis, there's
niqabis, and there's nifaqis. These
individuals who hold deep nifaq, uh
subhanallah, they hide it and they try
to they deny the hadiths, they deny the
hijab. Subhanallah, if it was a woman
who came out and done this, you know
what the conversation would be with a
lot of women? You deserve better. You do
this. He probably deserved it. Blah blah
blah blah blah. We as men, we don't do
that. I'm not going to come here and
make it seem as if he's a victim and
she's No, I'm so sorry. I know nothing
about it before anything. You may be
wrong, she may be wrong, I don't know.
I'm not here to talk about who's wrong.
I'm here to give genuine advice to
brother Ish and his wife if he's
watching this, and for those who are
going through divorce or getting
divorced. So, now, here's the video of
him He's in Mecca, if I'm not mistaken.
Habibi, if you are here off cameras, I
would love to speak to you. If there's
any support I can give you, you don't
need my support. I'm here. I'm here with
my shaikh as well. Inshallah, if you
would like to talk to us, any advice,
you're going through something, we're
here for you as your brothers. Here's a
uh other another video, inshallah. Let's
watch it.
Sometimes life moves way faster than you
expect. Before dropping a divorce video,
I told myself I am booking my flight to
Medina cuz that is the only way I'm
going to be able to block out your
stupid opinions. I booked 5 hours before
takeoff, and here I was saying salaam to
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam.
Anything could be happening in your
life, but when you're here, all you feel
is peace. This was my final day in
Medina, hopefully not my final salaam,
and I was off to the airport. I've been
raising money for the Gaza children that
have managed to cross the border into
Egypt this Ramadan, and I'm going to now
see them finally. It was iftar time, so
I just went to the first burger spot I
saw, I'm not going to lie. Guys, I don't
recommend breaking your fast alone.
Iftar is meant to be spent with family
and friends, man. Also, I definitely
recommend traveling in a four-wheel
drive. It's actually so comfy. The
Prophet said, Look at those who are
below you and not above you, for that is
more likely to prevent you from
belittling the blessings that Allah has
put upon you. So, the next stop, the
children of Gaza in Egypt.
Okay, so from that video, I can see
obviously the fact that he mentions do
not break the
Do not do not break your fast alone. I
can see this this pain there. And I
believe there's probably pain in the
sister side as well. Now, Islamically, I
don't know if you've given the three
talaqs. I follow the opinion of Ibn
Taymiyyah that
if you give 500 talaqs in one moment, it
counts as one talaq.
However, if you hold an opinion that
well, something else, you stick by that,
habibi. I can't do nothing about that.
You go to scholars and get fatwa for
that.
What I can see is this though, and I'm
talking to both of you guys. We ask
Allah subhana wa ta'ala in the holy
lands, wallahi, I make sincere dua, may
Allah subhana wa ta'ala, if there's
khair in both of you, may Allah re-
reunite you guys if the three talaqs
haven't taken place and the opinion that
you follow. I'll leave that to that. If
that's not the situation, I ask Allah
subhana wa ta'ala in these holy lands to
reunite you guys and make this affair
work if there's khair in it. Now, I want
to come to the crux of the matter. A lot
of times, people come to me and say,
"Brother,
sisters come to me and brothers come to
me and say, "Akhi,
I've done istikhara.
Why did I get divorced?"
And I'm like, "Okay." I was like,
"What's the confusion here?" And they
they get confused. They're like, "What
do you mean? I've done istikhara.
Istikhara was what? If that person's
good for me, that, you know, that Allah
let it be, and then we get married, and
things are happily ever after." And I'm
like, subhanallah, I don't think you've
understood what istikhara is. Now,
subhanallah, there is many verses we can
talk about, but let's
I'm going to come to about, you know,
living in peace and harmony together.
However, divorce is the haqq, and I've
always said this when I was talking
about that individual, this individual,
these nifaqis who were denying calling
for divorce, etc. Not a single place I
said divorce is haram, you should not
divorce. It's disliked. And Allah talks
in the Quran the severity of divorce.
And how shaytan in his throne gets happy
when one of his
little minions come and say, "Of course
divorce." He comes and says, "Sit in my
seat or come close to me." And also one
of the hadiths that the Prophet said, a
thing that is hate Something that's
halal that's hated and hated by Allah is
divorce. So, the point is this, brothers
and sisters. Istikhara is what? We need
to do istikhara. What do you say? I know
I've done istikhara before I was I got
married. If this person And istikhara is
not for marriage, guys. The Sahaba would
do istikhara to pick clothes.
This is the the relation they had with
Allah subhana wa ta'ala. Istikhara is
what? You are saying, "Oh Allah,
if this person is good for me in this
life and the hereafter, let it happen.
If it's not, move me away from them and
move them away from me." Okay? Because
you might be harmful for them. Istikhara
is not like you're an angel and you're
like, "Oh, no, no, you might be that
you're bad for them." The point here is
what and the key here is what, guys? Let
me put it into perspective. If you say,
and I'll give you a very fine example of
a brother that I know very closely who
got divorced, who has a child.
When he went through this, he said,
"Habibi, istikhara means what? If it's
good for your deen,
this dunya and the hereafter,
how could a divorce not be good for you?
Maybe that was the best thing. Let me
tell you how."
And that's why this smear campaign lies
against me about I'm against divorce.
This is absolute lies. You know why? Cuz
I've always been giving this advice. He
said and I've told him I said, "Habibi,
when he came to me," he said the same
thing, "Bro, I got divorced, blah blah
blah." I said, "Watch." I said, "Bro,
before this was you not struggling. It
was It was peak out there, yeah? You was
peak out there as a man. Okay, habibi,
you fulfilled your desires in a halal
way." And like the Prophet told the
Sahaba, "You get rewarded sadaqah when
you have an intimacy with your wife." He
said, "O Messenger of Allah,
reward?" He said, "Yes." And he said,
"How?" He said, "Do you not get a sin
when you commit zina?" He said, "Yes."
"Well, then you get rewarded when you
when you are having intimacy with your
wife."
Number one, you protect yourself from
zina halal. Allah gave you a wife to
have intimacy with in a halal way.
Number two, do you not have a daughter
now?" He said I said to him, he goes,
"Yes." I said, "Habibi, would you
ever Do you ever regret this?" He goes,
"Wallahi, well, she put me through hell,
whatever, but I will go and marry again
for that woman for my daughter." I said,
"Look, you got a beautiful daughter."
Number three, which is critical and
important to you, my brother Ish, and
your wife if you're watching this, and
anyone that's going through divorce. I
know many situations that an individual
went through one divorce, and that
divorce caused him to save his second
his marriage again. How?
Third thing that I told that brother was
what? Do you learn Did you learn things
from your this marriage that broke down?
He said, "Okay." "You're telling me that
it was her fault. No problem, let's go
with that argument cuz I know the ins
and outs of it. I can come and say,
'Okay, maybe she was to blame to certain
aspects, okay.' But, you wasn't an angel
also."
Did you learn lessons? Yes. Do you
accept that you also made certain
mistakes? Yes. Even though it might not
be the reason you went for divorce.
Okay.
Now, do you agree that the mistakes you
made here, you're not going to carry it
to your next marriage? He goes, "Yes."
Do you now know that because she put you
through hell, you are going to
appreciate your next wife even more?" He
goes, "Yes." I said, "Then, habibi, your
istikhara got answered beautifully, bro.
Protected you from zina, beautiful
daughter, and on top of that, you
learned lessons that you will not ruin
your marriage." And guess what? The
brother is now married happily, and he
says, "Wallahi, what I went through made
me appreciate this wife, for if I did
not go through that, I would have
destroyed this marriage.
Do you see? So, when you do istikhara,
don't look at istikhara or something
like, "Oh, I did istikhara, that means
my marriage is going to be successful."
It's might be that istikhara, that
marriage you're going through, is
preparing you for your ultimate
marriage. So, my advice to brother Ish
and his ex-wife,
if the free talks haven't happened, I
ask in these holy lands, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala reunite you guys. Believe me,
there's a lot of evil evil people out
there, specifically these [__] women
who sadly we're seeing that want
divorce. They misery loves company. They
want more people to get divorced. Break
break. Bro, they were calling for me and
my wife to get divorced, bro. They were
literally saying, you know, causing
fitna. Subhanallah. And when Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala protects the thing
I'm going to be relation with Allah, no
one, if the dunya came, all the nifaqis
came together, it would not harm. So, my
advice is that to you, my brothers and
sisters who are going through divorce,
or brother Ish and his wife, we ask
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala unite you
guys. If you see there's no May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala grant you guys both
better, inshallah. And for those who are
going through divorce,
do not despair. This is a trial that
happens, and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
will aid you. Have a strong relation
with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Pray
your salah. Give the of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala salah, zakah. Calculate your
zakah. Fasting. Okay. Give the of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Abstain from major
sins. Do your afkar. Be close to Allah.
Do istighfar in these moments, and you
will see Allah would never let their
servants with a test that they cannot
bear. Allah's doing this, and this this
is called Ish to come to the holy lands
to reconnect with his Lord. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala wants that for you.
And Ibn al-Qayyim says, and he quotes
from the salaf, that Allah inspires the
du'a that you make, bro. Allah sends you
to the holy lands and makes inspires you
in certain situations of calamity. Like
you might hate something which is good
for you, and you might love something
which is bad for you. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And what Allah says in the
Qur'an as well, he would never change
the condition of people until they
change what's within themselves. So,
look internally. Reflect inshallah for
both of you. Hopefully we hear the good
news that you guys are back together.
And if not, Allah has better plans for
you guys. And whoever's going through a
divorce, may Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
make it easy for you, especially our,
you know, subhanallah, single mothers
and single fathers as well. They both
suffer about one thing I will give an
advice on.
This happens as well from sister's side
as well, and some deadbeat men as well,
who do not see their kids after they're
divorced. Yes, cowardly men, I believe
this. Wallahi, I'm so sorry. Unless
they've been stopped. And sisters who
use their children against their
fathers.
This both of this one This one, like
I'll be honest with you. Both of them
are as bad as each other. But,
subhanallah, the one that's stopping
kinship, may Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
deal with him. That's what I would say,
inshallah, and hope inshallah we'll hear
the good news.
Little advice from me to you, habibi. We
are here in Mecca. If you would like to
talk to me off camera, inshallah we're
here. Till next time. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala protect our ummah
from divorce, so that future generations
can stronghold to the deen of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And even those who
are divorced, Allah will take care of
them, inshallah. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh.